un respiro para los habitantes de
Beijing tras el relajamiento de las
restricciones por parte del gobierno de
silvin las filas para realizarse las
pruebas Kobe 19 se han reducido
tengo la sensación de que los controles
son más laxos que antes y todo el mundo
está deseando salir todo el mundo se
siente más relajado y en muchos lugares
como One show schian la gente sale con
gusto de aquí para allá
las autoridades decidieron cerrar
temporalmente centros de detección del
virus pero a pesar de esto Aún se exigen
pruebas negativas para entrar a varios
lugares la gente debe Buscar los sitios
donde aún practican los tests
ha sido un inconveniente para nosotros
volver a nuestra ciudad natal para
visitar a nuestros padres también nos ha
resultado muy incómodo hacer viajes de
negocios para reunirnos con clientes el
número de nuevos casos diarios se redujo
en todo el país a 31.824 y dos personas
murieron por el virus según los últimos
datos revelados el autoproclamada
independiente isla de Taiwán dec se
reunieron en la Plaza de la libertad
Para apoyar a los que se manifiestan en
China continental contra las
restricciones
Di lo que pasó en internet y me rompió
el corazón
porcurriendo esto en 2022 Por eso estoy
aquí apoyo la democracia apoyo a la
libertad
también en otros países como Canadá o
Francia ha habido manifestaciones a
favor de las protestas en China